kitanji brown jackson made history as
the first black female nominee for the
supreme court but the tone of her
confirmation hearings before the senate
judiciary committee did not stray far
from that of other recent nominees
this is a historic hearing and a
historic nomination and so there is a
flavor there that we haven't had in
other recent hearings but in many ways
they are similar as in previous supreme
court nomination hearings senators
inquired about judge jackson's judicial
philosophy the sense you get from her
she has a very case by case fact by fact
approach
over the course of my uh almost decade
on the bench
i have developed
a methodology that i use
in order to ensure that i am ruling
impartially
and
that i am adhering
to the limits on my
judicial authority
i am acutely aware that as a judge in
our system
i have limited
power
and um i am trying in every case to stay
in my lane the one thing that was a
little bit notable she distanced herself
from this concept of the living
constitution which had been popular in
liberal circles for a while as sort of
the antidote to the conservative
original meaning of the constitution i
do not believe that there is uh
a living constitution in the sense that
it's changing and it and it's infused
with my own policy perspective or
uh you know the policy perspective of
the day
instead the supreme court has made clear
that
when you're interpreting the
constitution you're looking at the text
at the time of the founding as things
started out the temperature was low in
the room as the hearings went on it got
a little more charged which is how it
has been in past hearings
some of the most tense exchanges were
between judge jackson and republican
senators questioning her on her
sentencing record in child pornography
cases
you are looking at 30 40 50 years in
prison
good
good
absolutely good so you're not going to
answer my question no i've answered your
question in my answer you haven't
answered my question i'm sitting here
asking you and you're declining to
answer
i've sentenced more than a hundred
people you have eight or nine cases
in that chart okay judge you said that
before these are the eight or nine child
porn cases i will say to correct the
record i'll just say to the judge
there's no point in responding he's
going to interrupt you thanks look it's
certainly true that there are cases in
which judge jackson issued sentences to
child pornography defendants that were
below what sentencing guidelines
recommended but it's also true that the
sentencing guidelines on child
pornography cases are pretty out of date
there have been calls for them to be
updated there you know been bipartisan
agreement that in some cases the
guidelines are pretty harsh and so if
you look at the federal statistics here
more than two-thirds of child
pornography defendants are sentenced to
below guideline sentences even though
they're all still basically doing prison
time
after hours of difficult questioning
new jersey senator cory booker used his
allotted time to draw attention back to
the historic nature of the hearings
it's hard for me not to look at you and
not see my mom
i see my ancestors and yours
nobody's gonna steal the joy of that
woman in the street or the calls that
i'm getting or the texts
nobody's gonna steal that joy
you have earned this spot you are worthy
you are a great american
there was nothing that happened to this
week that really changed the trajectory
of what's going to happen here she came
into this hearing likely to be confirmed
she leaves the hearing likely to be
confirmed the democrats so long as they
stay together have the votes to confirm
her even if she doesn't get any
republican votes it would not prevent
her from sitting on the supreme court